here's what would happen if the Moon was
flat hey flat earthers there's a new
conspiracy in town flattening the moon
out would reduce it to 25 percent of its
current thickness with this much less
Mass floating above Earth watch for
drastic changes in Tides our Coastal
ecosystems would suffer and without
strong waves marine animals would die
off in masses these weak Tides would
cause extreme temperature fluctuations
but even climate wouldn't change as fast
as time say hello to the 15-hour long
day less time at work sounds like a plus
to me now we'd get more sunlight but as
a consequence nights would be even
darker a smaller Moon would be dimmer
and would throw navigation out of whack
for nocturnal animals now we're not
likely to see Earth's little buddy
flatten out anytime soon to become flat
the moon would need to spin so fast that
it would rip apart before having a
chance to flatten out so